our next guest cheering for her too is
Carly closed he does it all she's a
supermodel she's an entrepreneur she's a
philanthropist she's been modeling since
she was a teenager appearing in
countless magazines and walking a whole
lot of runways but guess what that's not
our only passion she is also a computer
coder the self-described nerd since when
Carly founded code with Posse in 2015 to
help girls become Future Leaders in Tech
the organization is free two-week summer
camps teach computer coding in app
building this year for the very first
time code with Claus is expanding
internationally wow that's great to
London that's in addition to their camps
in 19 U.S cities 5 000 campers will
receive full ride scholarship Carly this
is great I should have read this ahead
of time this is really wonderful what
you're doing go Carly be on the show
sometime and Carly joins us in the
studio I didn't know you were doing all
that bravo bravo bravo thank you so were
you a kid growing up and you were into
computers and coding you said let me
help others how did this come about for
you well long before I was in fashion
I've always always been a nerd and I
love math and science and but coding was
never something that was offered at my
school and it wasn't until I was meeting
through my career in fashion so many
entrepreneurs including my friend who
built Instagram and it clicked for me
one day I was like my friend who built
Instagram is that he he had the idea but
he had the technical skills to know how
to code and build a product that can
scale the world so I had this kind of
aha moment where I was like well I want
to learn that yeah and I realized first
of all I was the only girl in the
classroom when I was when I went to take
a coding boot camp you took a boot camp
I took a a boot camp which was an
intensive to learn these skills you're
the only girl in the class only girl in
the class and thought what well that
that first of all these skills are
possible to learn why didn't I learn
them sooner and women are
underrepresented unfortunately the
gender the gender gap is very real and
this technology that the technology
that's built touches all of our lives so
we all need to be a part of informing
how it's built so then you said I'm
going to help other girls is that how it
came about well I started on social
media this was almost a decade ago and I
had on Instagram many you know followers
young women primarily and I thought what
can I tell them and I wanted them to
have this opportunity to learn how to
code and realize the potential in these
spaces like what because people don't
really know what happens with coding we
need a lot of code what does it open the
world to you to do what you can build
and you can take your idea and bring it
to life you can build I mean the amount
of projects around climate change social
justice I mean we have Scholars who
can't vote but they're building apps and
websites to inform people on voting
rights
um it's incredible and this Summer Gail
so when I started we had 21 scholarships
I I had this experience myself I
underwrote 21 scholarships not thinking
it would you know be anything and we had
thousands of applications for those 21
spots so I started code with classy and
now this summer we're going into our
biggest summer yet 5 000 scholarships
for free so five thousand yes five
thousand dollars amazing and you and she
did that guys you did that Carly thank
you that is awesome yes you know when
you talk about coding
um like you say it is a superpower
because you talk to individuals that are
really good at it and it's like they're
speaking a different language but it's
impressive and you want to learn
um and there's no barriers when your
mind is so open so free and filled with
so much information but there are
barriers for young girls what are some
of those obstacles that you see in the
way of women getting into this Tech
space well I think it's intimidating and
I think that's the reason why a lot of
people self-select out but it is it's a
creative skill set that can it's a
problem-solving skill set you can
creatively build any idea and and build
a business or create the change in the
world that you want to create I just
think this is so exciting and I just
love your passion I've seen you working
with these young girls Your Enthusiasm
is infectious but most of them know you
because you were Carly cause supermodel
we've got the first video of your first
runway show back in the day do you
remember this got it oh my God we
actually have it we're going to play it
up oh my god oh walk you look at that
girl you look at that girl and you think
what Carly cause compared to look at you
I remember how nervous I was I felt
totally too nervous you were nervous
Beyond but it's not the same week I
started my freshman year of high school
okay I was just as much a nerd then as I
am now yes oh my gosh yes and when you
look at her and you think what today
myself in so many of the scholars that
are in our community and I I you know I
think I want them to realize and one 15
year old me to realize that I have and
we all have infinite potential and you
just need access to the right community
and right opportunities to realize that
and that is really what we're doing at
code with Classy to help these young
women realize their potential in any
space they want to go into you're also a
Levi's mom she's also a mom you have a
two-year-old I can't wait to see what
you will teach him in this world
possibly coding yeah
for sure coding it does how to do that
walk also
thank you very much